so today we're going to talk about three
aspects of mentorship one is how mentors
can help change your life then different
levels of mentorship and last but not
least how for you to approach a mentor
so hopefully they can mentor you
so stick around to the very end to get
the pdf of everything we're talking
about today in regards to mentoring so
let me get right into it the number one
point
in why and how a mentor can change your
life it's really
the most important point is speed here's
what i mean by speed the right mentor
can teach you what you can learn in two
years in six months the question becomes
where a lot of people say you don't need
a mentor you can still win without a
mentor are they wrong no they're
absolutely right however
what you can do on your own and figure
it out on your own by taking you know
whatever books you read and all this
other stuff and no one-on-one
relationship with a mentor
that may take you 12 years that may take
you 15 years but with the right mentor
you may do it in six years or five years
or four years the main difference that
you're doing difference is you're
condensing time frames if you have the
right mentor and you're lengthening it
if you try to do it all on your own
point number two the right mentor gives
you a safe zone very similar to how matt
damon in the movie goodwill hunting
finally felt safe around robin williams
and he opened up the right mentor is
going to make you feel that way you can
be vulnerable and really have deeper
conversations with them to help you
elevate to the next level there's a
there's a a a a brother and a sister
team that i'm mentoring they run a
medical billing business themselves and
they're doing very well but
the older sister and the younger brother
six years or so
they have a fighting going on between
two of them and the younger brother is
the ceo and she's the ceo and they're
fighting he's like well sometimes she's
condescending towards me and all this
other stuff and and you know i have
these fears and insecurity and she
messes with my ego you see you can't
talk about that publicly with other
people you need an outlet to have that
conversation with them and we addressed
it and they understood how to go about
it and they moved on and their business
growing they're doing well
those types of conversations has to be
had somewhere because if you just try to
bottle it in with your partner you can't
really get past it you're gonna hit a
plateau every time so the other benefit
of having a great mentor is you can
process issues with a person that you
feel safe talking to them about point
number three the right coaches always
give you an out meaning it's a binary
they'll give you their feedback and
they'll say look here's what i would do
if i'm in your situation you don't have
to do this you have these choices you
can do this you can do this you can do
this if you do this these are the
consequences these are the positives if
you do this these are the consequences
if you do this this is what's going to
happen which way do you want to go let's
process it together and you go from
there but the right mentors are not
going to give you this they're going to
give you multiple ways to get to where
you want to go to and then you're going
to have to make a decision which route
you want to take point number four the
right mentor is not afraid of
challenging you simple as that they'll
say to you yeah i think you're just
making excuses you're like what yeah i
think you're making i think you're
afraid what do you mean yeah i i think
you're being lazy i think you've been
cocky right you've been making a lot of
money and
quite frankly i think you forgot who you
were i think you think you're better
than your employees
and you totally forgot about what it was
like to build a company when you were
smaller what happened to you
do you not sit there and you know talk
about the vision and the mission of the
company anymore i feel like you've
gotten a little bit too much about just
money and the lifestyle and all this
stuff you've forgotten what really
matters why you started this company in
first place i can't believe you said
that to me i'm not trying to make your
friend i'm not trying to make you happy
not going to sit or tell you're amazing
all the time i'm telling you you're
getting in your own way right now go
back and read the original
reason why you started this company so
you can remember it was hard then came
logic now you're all only thinking
they're willing to have a conversation
like that with you great mentors will do
that to you and uh most of the time
you're gonna feel a little bit
uncomfortable with the right mentors so
point number five say you get a new
mentor okay and you start getting close
to this mentor
the more you get closer to this advisor
mentor whatever you want to call it
eventually
you're going to get access to their
circle
so their contacts of people they do
business with is now yours as well okay
and by the way typically the best
mentors are a little bit protective of
giving the access too early because they
don't know what your motives are yet
maybe they'll watch you a little bit and
then they'll give you a little bit of a
sprinkle of access and you're like okay
that was kind of cool
but they're not yet sprinkling the real
access that you got and then eventually
you're like oh okay
i've really earned this person's trust
then they open it up once they open up
their access of their contacts to you
you go from living in a world like this
to living in a world like this so there
is just as much
pressure on you
to deliver
on you being serious to commit to your
mentor and work your advisor because if
you don't they're going to go find
somebody else great mentors don't lack
mentees it's mentees that lack great
mentors the market is
very much looking for great mentors
mentees are everywhere everybody's
asking can you mentor me can you mentor
me can you mentor me can you mentor me
from great mentors everybody else but
the mentors hand select so once you go
in you earn the right to be mentored by
them you're gonna get access to who they
have which can completely change your
life point number six is style if you
ever notice someone's style of how they
are how they communicate how do they
process issues how they solve problems
and you go and find out who mentored
them you will notice similarity with the
style of play okay style of decision
making this is in baseball this isn't
sports this is in business this isn't
raising money this is in any thing that
you pretty much do you're gonna get that
personal style of leadership so
the right mentor style if they mentor
you long enough you essentially are
taking and receiving their style of
processing that you start implementing
to your life and by the way what's crazy
about it is
6 12 24 36 months from now when you
start picking that up all of a sudden
you'll do something you'll say oh my god
that's what that's what she does
why that's what that's crazy i'm
naturally now doing it and i'm not even
aware of it that's what's gonna happen
if you got the right mentor so point
number seven is the right mentor gives
you different lens meaning if you have
this lens you see the world and you put
the lens of a mentor over then all of a
sudden you're seeing things you're not
seeing anyone because they're creative
in the way they do things meaning
they're creative ways on how for you to
raise 10 million bucks but you didn't
have that before
they'll share with you creative ways on
how to hire the right
cfo you're trying to hire that you
didn't have before the creative ways out
how for you to expand in a new market
that you didn't know how to do before
launch a new product that you didn't
know how to do before build a new
division that you didn't know how to do
before because they allow you to borrow
their lens and they're creative in the
way they got to where they're at right
now so the right mentor will share with
you creative ways of getting things that
you want now
point number eight is when you borrow an
advisor's way of thinking a crisis that
was a nine before is all of a sudden a
five a crisis that would make you lose
sleep at night oh my god it's the end of
the world they're like no here's all you
need to do boom boom boom oh
so it's not an 8 no it's a four
oh got it okay so let me go ahead and do
that so
while you feel like it's the end of the
world
they make you feel it's okay it's part
of the process and here's what you need
to do which makes you be a little bit
more poised and you make better
decisions not at a place of reacting and
emotional but at a place of reason logic
and vision point number nine is very
simple it's accountability if you have a
great leader that's not afraid of
holding you accountable you're gonna
improve in areas that you're not paying
attention to it's that simple you need
accountability and the best mentors are
great at holding people accountable
point of return is there's levels to
mentorship okay let me explain to what i
mean by this i may be a great a
specialized mentor in an area of
business right
but if you ask me to be your mentor to
teach you piano i'm a zero i don't know
how to play the piano i may be a great
mentor in an area of you saying pat i
want to go out there and figure out
about how to market and tell my story
better as a company to go get a half a
million clients okay that's my specialty
that's what i've done we have nearly
half a million insurance clients over
the last 12 and a half years i know how
to show you how to do that because
that's my area of expertise ask me how
to edit a video i have no clue how to
edit a video except for my phone when
i'm making small stuff or tic toc and
instagram right so again your mentor may
be great
in the way i would put it for you to
visually see it put your put yourself as
areas that you're an expert at and score
them so okay in the game of soccer i'm a
six i played in high school put a little
college okay great baseball i'm a five
okay
raising money i'm a zero coding i'm an
eight okay finances and accounting i'm a
five
okay when it comes down to sales and
negotiation i'm a nine that's your area
of expertise right the same way with
mentors you want to work with the key is
to find as specialized as possible
rather than generalized here's one thing
you need to know as well as you're newer
and you're coming up you're typically
not going to get the best coaches and
mentors one mentors one because you
can't afford it two you haven't yet
proven yourself that you're ready to
compete at that level three even if you
got that best mentor to mentor you you
would not have a clue what they're
talking about for example imagine if
your 12 year old kid who just started
playing basketball three months ago and
you say i want to go find the best
mentor where's phil jackson
and phil jackson starts talking to your
12 year old kid about triangle offense
your son's like mom what the hell was
this man talking about
he kept talking about triangle the
entire time what is a triangle offense i
don't know what it is i don't think this
basketball thing is for me right versus
that 12 year old kid could have learned
how to play basketball by a sophomore in
high school could have told them how to
dribble and how to do crossover and how
to shoot and you know elbow all the
basic stuff right so some of you are so
eager about finding the best mentor too
early even if you got him or her you
would not be able to get the most out of
them first you got to climb up the
ladder and learn the basics and maybe a
little bit more about the basics then
the higher laws
then the specialized mentor starts
showing up so there's the understanding
of knowing
what is the difference between a
generalized mentor and a specialized
mentor by the way in regards to
mentoring with specialized let's just
say eventually you end up finding a
specialized mentor the guys that or kind
of people that everybody wants to be
mentored by say you're lucky enough and
fortunate enough to get one of those
people great here's the sensitivity part
of it that it's unspoken not a lot of
people talk but i just want to kind of
give it to you if you do get a person
like that mentoring you if they sense
all of a sudden that you're no longer
coachable learning
implementing they give you a challenge
of an article to read a book to read a
video to watch
something to study and you no longer do
it they disappear like this and they
move on and then you'll try to get a
hold of him you're like well wait a
minute when i used to call him five
times he used to answer the call four
out of five times yeah
now i call him five times he only
answers one out of five times is that
intentional
uh it is just so you know that that's
very intentional because it's not like
there's doing it oh it's five four out
of five no it's just in their mind
they don't want to talk to somebody
where they feel like they're forcing
them to do something that they no longer
want to do they don't want to be a pest
to somebody else and they feel if you're
no longer taking a feedback and you're
no longer wanting to be a student no
problem i don't want to be a pest i
don't want to challenge you or push you
anymore go do what you want to do it's
all good i got to move on you got to be
aware of that with specialized mentors
they're not going to wait too long if
you don't show the hunger that you once
had to learn from them so now in regards
to approaching a mentor i will tell you
i've done this to many many different
people over throughout my life and i'll
tell you what's worked and what's didn't
i reached out to a mentor of mine dudley
rutherford i went and heard him speak at
a church and i said i want this guy as a
mentor and uh i emailed them in the
email and i
said i'd like to get closer to you at
that time i was 25 years old i said i
don't have much to offer to you today
but i promise you i'm working on myself
to be able to return any kind of value
you're gonna give me i'm gonna do my
best to give it back to you
i knew when i sent the first email i'm
probably not gonna hear back from him
because i just know that's kind of how
this works he's got 20 000 members they
want his time i'm one person and i have
nothing to offer in return well took a
year and a half after multiple follow-up
where he responded back we had lunch we
got close the rest is history i changed
my wedding day just so he could marry me
he sat on my board he made a very nice
video something he had never done for a
company before ever
and to the point where that video was
like why would you do this for him you
haven't done this video for any other
business owner in the entire san
fernando valley and that video is still
out there we can take a look at it but
and then from there by the way no money
was given nothing to the church i'll
give you money to do zero nothing
and then the relationship became a
friendship and anytime he asked me for
stuff that he wants to the best of my
abilities i go above and beyond to help
him out family himself son no matter
what it is right
so you approach the higher level you
approach
knowing
they may not
follow up with you because there's more
of you than him or her the mistake a lot
of times people make is i can't believe
i emailed him three times he hasn't gone
back to me
well guess what if that's the approach
you have with the person that doesn't
get back to you maybe you're not cut out
to get to the next level in business in
the first place
to address and approach the right mentor
requires a lot of patience from your end
until they say yes and once they do
you best exchange value you best bring
value you best keep your word if you got
a meeting at 4 with them show up at 3 45
every time you leave a meeting with them
send them a book send them a gift send
them a card send them send them
something so where they're like oh my
god this guy's on top of this stuff i've
mentored a lot of different people
nobody is this hungry about wanting to
learn from me as this guy i've never met
anybody like this before
they admire other hungry people because
that's how they used to be when they
were coming up as a mentee learning from
a mentor so that's the approach i
suggest you take with them and
eventually hopefully the people that you
want mentoring you eventually some of
them will say yes to you because the
right ones can change your life so if
you want the entire message i give to
you in a pdf click on a link below to
get the whole thing in a pdf as well as
if you do want to watch a video a little
bit more in the content like this i gave
a talk a few months ago uh in regards to
what makes
the difference between those in the top
one percent that win at the highest
level and the rest that don't if you've
not watched that talk before click here
to watch that video it's called will
versus want with that being said have a
great day everybody take care bye
[Music]